with six days left to the election it's
incredible how little public discourse
this past year's had to do with the
actual issues immigration has become a
meme fest revolving around Trump's
proposed wall abortion was basically
relegated to one three-minute exchange
in the final debate there's been
virtually nothing on legalizing
marijuana the war on drugs or reforming
our prison system foreign policy has
been reduced to trump saying he can't
tell us what he's gonna do so that he
doesn't tip anyone off versus Hillary
promoting her experience much of which
was a disaster there's been pretty much
no talk of infrastructure or education
but a whole lot on genital grabbing and
hacked emails my hope is that this is
the last election will ever have where
seemingly every major issue is neglected
in the minutiae of he-said she-said get
center stage out of all of this anger
and frustration in general lunacy I
really do believe that something good
will rise from the ashes the majority of
us want to talk about the real issues we
don't want to demonize everyone we don't
want to be pandered - and we do want to
find solutions we got in this political
mess this year because for so long we've
allowed the system to let the lowest
common denominator rise to the top maybe
we needed this freak show to happen so
that the masses the silent majority
would finally wake up and realize that
it's actually our lives our welfare and
our families on the line every
generation is something new to fight for
it may be for this generation the fight
will be to recreate a system by the
people and for the people that's why the
next few years are gonna be an
incredibly important piece of history
well we sit back and let the worst of us
continue to take control or will we
fight back will we find allies where we
used to find enemies and where we stand
for principles even when it's not
popular to do so I really believe that
we'll do the right thing but the only
way we'll do it is by really discussing
issues and not the sideshow let's demand
that our leaders explain why they
believe in what they believe why they
vote the way they vote and why they
deserve the right to speak for us as
citizens let's step back from the
scandals in the screaming and focus
education and empowerment politicians
and the media aren't gonna magically
just become better we have to demand
that they do and the only way that we
can demand it is if we demand it from
ourselves we can start by being
outspoken instead of just outraged this
week we're continuing our collaboration
with learn Liberty we're teaming up with
learning Liberty once a month to talk to
professor's thought leaders and authors
on a wide variety of topics all related
to free speech and classical liberalism
two things we could certainly use a
little more of these days joining me
this week is dr. Steve Davies dr. Davies
is head of education at the Institute of
Economic Affairs in London he's also a
lecturer and a historian whose research
includes crime and criminal justice the
history of ideas and political thought
comparative economic history and much
more in short this guy knows his stuff
and we're gonna get into all of it or at
least as much as we can in an hour so
sit back take a break from the sound
bites and distractions and open your
minds to the issues that matter your
brain will thank you and your country
will too
you